en nuestro espacio de economía hoy
hablaremos de la reforma tributaria que
presentó el gobierno chileno de gabriel
boric y para hablar de esto está con
nosotros nuestra periodista daniela
blandón daniela bienvenida y empecemos
hablando de que es esta reforma o la
maria clara pues chile es uno de los
países de la ocde con mayor desigualdad
de ser también este conocido como el
club de países ricos por eso el gobierno
busca recaudar unos 12 mil millones de
dólares adicionales anuales la reforma
fiscal entonces se compone de cambios en
los impuestos a las grandes empresas
también la imposición de un nuevo
tributo al patrimonio financiero e
inmobiliario herramientas para poner
freno a la evasión fiscal y una mayor
contribución por parte de las mineras el
objetivo de una reforma tributaria es
justamente avanzar en mayor equidad
avanzar en mayor igualdad avanzar en
mayor posición social
para que
todos estemos un poquito más protegidos
esta reforma tributaria
responde a la idea de un pacto fiscal
que aporte al desarrollo del país que
ayude a modernizar el sistema tributario
que le dé más justicia al sistema de
impuestos y que sea eficiente tanto en
lo que es la recaudación como en el uso
de los recursos y una de las grandes
preguntas es qué va a pasar con la
minería que es uno de los puntos más
fuertes de chile bueno pues chile es el
principal productor de cobre del mundo y
con esta reforma las grandes mineras
tendrán que pagar más ya no una
contribución fija sobre sus ventas sino
que tendrán otro componente ligado
directamente al precio internacional
conversamos sobre este tema con álvaro
merino él es gerente de estudios de la
sociedad nacional de minería que es el
gremio que aglutina a las grandes
empresas mineras
a este respecto yo creo que hay que
tener presente un aspecto que es clave y
es la competitividad
muchos muchos países tienen recursos
mineros lo cierto pero algunos de ellos
no lo han explotado y no lo han
explotado por precisamente por la
institucionalidad que se han dado y
chile ha tenido un cambio
radical en las últimas tres cuatro
décadas y eso se debe fundamentalmente a
la institucionalidad que se dio el país
no es cierto para desarrollar su minería
y en esta institucionalidad es clave
clave la certeza jurídica y la
estabilidad en las normas que regulan la
actividad y este tema se vuelve más
complejo porque el cobre está en su
mínimo de precios en el último año y
medio sí pues este proyecto llega en un
momento en el que el descenso de los
precios internacionales del cobre
amenaza la economía chilena primero es
bueno recordar para qué sirve el cobre
el cobre es un metal básico lo cierto en
el mundo moderno y el cobre se usa
fundamentalmente
en la
en obras de infraestructura y
construcción es el principal conductor a
nivel mundial es el mejor metal no es
cierto para conducción eléctrica ahora
hablando de precios al contrato de
compra del metal rojo a 3 meses en la
bolsa de londres sólo el viernes cayó un
2,7 por ciento un poco más de ocho mil
dólares la tonelada y llegó a caer a su
nivel más bajo desde febrero de 2021 y
en el trimestre cayó un 20 por ciento
como no lo hacía desde 2011
la disminución en la cotización del
cobre se explica fundamentalmente
por los crecientes temores a que un
endurecimiento de la política monetaria
por parte de los bancos centrales lleve
a una recesión mundial lo que
naturalmente no es cierto ello va a
contraer la demanda por metales y
particularmente en el caso de el cobre
chileno es el único impactado daniela
que pasa en américa latina pero también
es un gran productor de la región y en
chile aunque hay que decir que chile es
el más grande del mundo por ejemplo en
este país el dólar están máximos frente
al peso por esta situación veamos la
importancia para esta economía
específicamente
la principal exportación del país es
precisamente el cobre y el cobre
representa aproximadamente el 90 por
ciento del pib minero y el pil minero en
los últimos 15 años más o menos ha
representado alrededor del 12 al 13 por
ciento del pib del país por cada centavo
adicional
promedio anual que aumenta la cotización
del cobre
aumentan los ingresos por concepto de
exportaciones en 125 millones de dólares
y el fisco aumenta sus ingresos en 60
millones de dólares maría clara hicieron
con este dato de todo el cobre que se
produce en el mundo el 52% se lo consumo
china increíble gracias daniela por esta
información y nosotros seguimos con más
aquí en france 24
[Música]